the penultimate episode of the final
season of game of thrones
involved a major battle at king's
landing and things took
a very dark turn here are 17 details you
might have missed
and warning spoilers are coming
once again in this episode we saw the
title sequence change
in this week's opening credits one major
change we see scorpions
those giant crossbow-like weapons that
qyburn created to slay dragons
sitting atop the walls at king's landing
the episode opens with varus writing a
letter
about jon snow's true parents it's a
mirror of the letter ned stark wrote to
stannis baratheon back in season 1
exposing that jaime lannister is a true
father of cersei's children
not robert baratheon you will sail to
dragonstone tonight
you will place this in the hand of
stannis baratheon lord baelish like
tyrion tavares in the last episode
tries to convince ned to drop it and
allow joffrey to take the throne
he would be wise to deny it to him and
to make sure joffrey succeeds
and like ned varus pays the price for
his actions with his life
there appear to be multiple letters
varys is writing could he have sent them
out already
and to whom would he have sent them as
varus writes his letters he's
interrupted by marta
a little girl acting as one of his spies
we've actually seen marta before
she was hiding in the crypt along with
varys during the battle of winterfell in
episode 3.
back in season 7 episode 2 dany tells
varys
if you ever betray me i'll burn you
alive
well it's clear danny made good on that
promise when tyrion sets jaime free to
go rescue cersei
jaime says cersei once called me the
stupidest lannister that's a call back
to
season 7 episode 7. expedition news
i always knew you were the stupidest
cersei was berating jaime for heading
north
to fight against the threat beyond the
wall this conversation was the last time
jaime and cersei saw each other
and takes place in the exact same spot
where they were reunited as the red keep
crumbled in this episode
more on jaime's and cersei's deaths in a
bit we get this scene of dany's armies
charging against the remaining golden
company
forces after a large chunk of them are
blown away by drogon's fire
the shot is a mirror image of the battle
of the bastards
when jon is faced with an onslaught of
men and horses but unlike john's heroic
fighting stance
harry strickland the leader of the
golden company runs for his life
as dany burns the outer wall at king's
landing we see
cersei standing in the exact same spot
she stood when she burned down the sept
of baelor
back in season six only this time she's
on the losing side
that danny's dragon drogon would fly
over king's landing was foreshadowed
in bran's vision in season 4 episode 2
as he touches the weirwood tree
bran saw the shadow of a dragon above
the rooftops
as the hound attempts to convince arya
to leave the red keep instead of going
to kill cersei
he grabs her and shouts look at me the
hound does the same thing during the
battle of blackwater in season 2
with sansa after she refuses to flee
king's landing with him
this shows the hound's ark with the
stark daughters
look at me cleganebowl
finally happened which certainly comes
as no surprise but what is significant
about the showdown is that the hound
dies
with the zombified mountain by falling
into the fiery city below
the hound is deathly afraid of fire
because his brother put his face into a
fire
when they were children but as the
show's producer describes it
the one thing stronger in the hound than
his fear of fire
is the hatred for the person who put
that fear there in the first place
in season three episode nine as arya and
the hound travel
arya tells him someday
i'm gonna put a sword through your eye
and out the back of your skull
that's exactly what the hound ends up
doing to his brother the mountain
game of thrones is no stranger to the
occasional celebrity cameo
here we see green bay packers
quarterback aaron rodgers playing the
role of a man in king's landing
helping a woman who was injured we hear
a familiar
composition at two different points
during the episode the reigns of
castamere
plays once as cersei realizes she must
flee the red keep
[Music]
and when jamie and cersei face certain
death it's a mix of that song
with the light of the seven
it's a clue that these characters won't
survive the episode
season three episode nine is called the
reigns of castamere and we hear the song
during the famous red wedding
the light of the seven composition
though refers back to cersei's victory
in season six
this episode saw the deaths of twins and
lovers cersei and jaime lannister
experiencing one final embrace before
the red keep collapses upon them
this moment was foreshadowed back in
season 5 when braun asks jaime how he
would want to die
and jaime replies
and it appears he does just that there
are other moments from the book that
foreshadowed this moment
in the books jaime says i cannot die
while cersei lives we will die together
as we were born together and the show
adapted this line from the book back in
season one
jamie and i are more than brother and
sister we shared a wound
came into this world together we belong
together in season 2 episode 10
dany had a vision upon entering the
house of the undying she sees the throne
room at king's landing and shambles
with snow falling from above though we
don't see it in this episode the throne
room is most certainly torn apart
but that falling snow looks a lot like
the ashes falling from the sky
could this be what danny saw in the
prophecy way back then
or is the snow a reference to jon snow
sitting on the throne after she wreaks
havoc at king's landing
bran also sees a similar image of the
throne room in his season 4 vision
finally we see a white horse standing in
the middle of the ruins of king's
landing
arya rides the horse out of the city
white horses in mythology
often symbolize triumph but in
christianity they can also herald death
like in the book of revelation or is
this a reference to shadow facts in lord
of the rings
shadow facts
[Music]
is the lord of all horses it's also
worth noting that the young girl arya is
unable to save is holding on
to a little white horse did we miss
anything let us know in the comments